>>Narrator: Over the
past several years,
there's been a quiet revolution going
on that has transformed Harrison
High School's curriculum.
In almost every classroom, technology
tools are facilitating a new way
of learning.
>>Are we collecting?
>>Narrator: Probes
and laptops are used
in real world scientific
explorations.
History lessons are as
exciting as game shows.
>>A, Colorado, B.
>>Narrator: They even use technology
to improve their nationally
ranked cheerleading squad.
>>Student: Like without this
stuff, we'd have no idea
like how much things have
changed in, you know,
where we started and
where we're at now.
It lets people know that they've
either been working hard enough
or need to work a little bit harder.
>>Narrator: Data from the cheerleader
workouts is given to students
in an algebra two class for analysis.
>>Charlotte: These students are just
learning how to graph equations,
and instead of just plain graphing
numbers, we're graphing real data,
so they can have something
meaningful for their work.
>>Student: Right now,
I'm tracing myself
so I can determine by
velocity of the ball.
>>Narrator: In this physics
class, students use video cameras,
photo gates and other
high tech gadgets
to explore the science behind
their personal passions.
>>Teacher: If you consider a
minute ago, you went from up there
to the floor in a thirtieth
of a second.
So your acceleration and your
average velocity was a lot faster.
>>All: [cheering]
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org